hey welcome to a new project camp update
in this video we're going to talk about
some fire issues here on the land we're
going to clean up some oak trees
and i'm going to show you some research
we've been doing with different types of
wood and different types of coating
[Music]
the big problem on the land is that it
burned down two times in the recent
years in 2005 and 2017 and when we
bought the land we were looking for it
this was actually all just flat and
burnt down sticks and wood and all the
trees were not there yet
so there used to be this pine forest
here which yeah all traces of burn
so everything you see now grew back in
the last four years
and the way it seems like a good thing
but not really because what grows back
is eucalyptus or mimosa trees
and they are non-native trees so they
don't come from here and the downside is
they grow so fast that they take away
all the shade for the other trees that's
supposed to be here so they used to be
here an oak tree a cork tree chestnut
tree but because these plants are so
invasive they take over the whole space
and the other ones can grow
so if you want to make a healthy forest
with native trees we need to make sure
we get rid of all the invasive trees
so here's one of the few old trees on
the land it's a cork tree also burned as
you can see um but this one is still
alive and starts to sprout again mainly
because the tree is more resilient to
fire it has a thick bark so you can
really reduce a little bit the fire risk
by planting the right trees
to make like a fire wall
so our long-term goal here would be to
replace all the mimosas and eculeptus
trees with the native trees but one
better thing we can actually already do
in the short term is if we see a native
tree like this oak here it's a young oak
that tries to grow
to give it the space to grow and make
sure it doesn't get overtaken by mimosas
which is usually the case
so today we're going to free up some
native trees cut the mimosas around it
to make sure they can grow and become
strong resilient trees
all right so today we're going to start
to clean up some native trees and give
them some more space we're going to do
it today because also some local people
started to clean the electricity line
underneath it needs to be cleaned so
we're going to join forces and get rid
of some mimosas and ecliptus trees so
the oaks and the corks can grow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so not more
just that the oak can grow
freely right this is the point okay
look as you can see here there's a
really nice oak tree now fresh in the
leaf because you can also see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we want to help them
get a better start
and get around it to give them more
space
why is it so loud here
yes these are our friends they are
helping to cut the electricity lines
we woke this was our
alarm clock this morning
what time
six six in the morning
but it's okay
they're good people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
we are freeing that crazy oak tree and
we are almost there we can have a look
now and it looks
quite good and
i think it's happy to have some sunlight
again like at the hairdresser
like a doctor like a hairdresser more
[Music]
can i have your little
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
as you can see here they're still
standing some dead trees
they're leaning on top of all the
mimosa and
other trees standing around the oak and
the willows you want to save
so we have to get them down otherwise
they will fall on the people cutting
down there
so good to do it now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so one of the main reasons to get rid of
mimosas is to bring back the native
trees
but also to make the land a bit more
fire resilient because as you can see
they burn very fast and this is a fresh
cutted mimosa tree
so yeah we tried to get rid of them and
plant bags more like forks
oats chestnuts because they're a bit
more fire resilient
and now we're also getting rid of all
the
organic material to make sure it doesn't
burn in the summer when it gets very dry
so we keep the fire roots in the useful
wood this is more the burnable leftover
not an ideal scenario ideally we have a
wood chipper but we're still saving for
a tractor
[Music]
all right so that was it end of the day
we cleaned up this area i have a few
trees that are now free some oaks willow
and the eel flower there in the
background coming
was a bit more difficult than expected
because there was just a lot of that old
trees in there which we had to drag out
but generally this is something we just
have to keep on going still a big land
to go many trees to free up
so yeah you can also come and join and
help us
but for now that was it and we continue
another time
well then
[Music]
oh my god
we'll leave the window tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
this is super weird
[Music]
and we don't even use it that's the
worst thing
so what happened to you
they've cleaned up
they cleaned up around the electricity
poles because it's mandatory 15 meters
each side to make sure the trees don't
hit the electricity wire so every five
years they would clean it especially the
fast growing trees so now it's very bare
land looking at a very
beautiful electricity pool
research time
so what's great about this project is
that besides all the things we are
building the whole day some beautiful
some very functional there's also a lot
of time and space to really experiment
and try out different things there's a
whole section on the website where you
can see all our projects that we are
currently working on and you can
participate in to help us come with
solutions we didn't think about
so for this experiment we're gonna try
and find out to find the answer to the
next question so what are the different
types of wood we can use on the lens
that come from around here and what's
the best way to protect them long term
from all the weather influences
for this experiment we used five
different types of wood this time we
choose the most common and available
wood types for this region
all the five types are
vine
red cedar
[Music]
eucalyptus poplar
and multiplex
then we took eight different treating
methods
so for the first one we did no treatment
at all the second one is old candle wax
which is nice because it's a waste
product
for the third one we used raw linseed
oil and then the fourth one we used
boiled linseed oil
the fifth one is a ready to go product
it's called bondex
it's the only product that's not natural
or a waste product just to see what
would happen
the sixth thing we used is old engine
oil
this oil comes from rita's old car which
he donated to the project
a lot of you guys and also the local
people recommended us to use it
it's a chemical product but still kind
of cool because it's also a waste
product that we can reuse
the seventh one is a burn technique
and the last one the eighth one is teak
oil
so as you can see here i made a little
fire
to do the burning of the wood
you see it a lot online people burning
with flamethrower
but they for the try the original way
and then
on a wood fire
and the the key
of course is to get an evenly
burnt surface
so when you burn one piece of the wood
too much
then it won't be strong enough anymore
and if you burn it too little then it
won't protect enough so you want a nice
equal surface
so that's why i made a fire like this
and
you put it on
and just wait for a while
maybe move it a bit
see where my pliers are here
[Music]
as you can see now it's
a bit burning the surface
like this starts to get like the
crocodile
it needs to get to be super black
it has to be black yes
it really has to burn
and then afterwards
as you can see now we re a really nice
equally burnt surface
this should protect the wood from
bacteria and fingers
and also protect it from
burning another time
because the burnt wood burns less quick
than the fresh wood
all right
we made the board with all the samples
on it
different type of treatments
everything is ready screwed we made a
decent structure
which you can put somewhere and which
will stay for a couple of years strong
enough to
carry the load
and we found a nice place
to put everything
and let the weather do its magic or it's
dead or it's
how you call it that
there's here sun rain shade
all you want
and uh
maybe you should note that the
we place it under an angle
so every type of wood
gets
a bit of the same exposure to rain
and this can also be
drip a bit of it it takes a bit longer
so
the
wedding ring goes a bit faster
all right
ready
i'm ready
mm-hmm
let's go
all right we want to put it a bit off
the ground so the
the
grass and everything that grows here
doesn't influence the
results
nice crew
i like it
this will survive
all right so now the tests are all here
we just have to wait for the weather and
the time to see what it does and we
document this process online in the
research module make some updates every
now and then so if you want to follow it
make sure to go there
and that was it for this video in the
next video we're going to start cleaning
up the small rune we have down there
seeing what we're going to do with it so
it's going to be exciting if you already
want to see that video you can support
on patreon if not we'll just see you
again next week same time same channel
thanks for watching
[Music]
you